okay guys let's cut right to the chase
on this one we talked to t fus lawyer
and he helped us clarify a lot of the
parts of the Tipu versus faze clan
lawsuit he talked about what he said is
the most shocking part of T Fu's
original game were agreement he talked
about the $60,000 figure gave us some
completely new information on the whole
case and even issued a challenge to faze
clan alright guys so as you know for a
few weeks now we have been following
very closely the case of the t food vs.
faze clan lawsuit we broke down the
lawsuit t pues original contract and the
ongoing situation with underage streamer
hi sky now if you haven't watched those
videos pause this one click right above
my head and open them in a new tab
because there's a lot to go over and I
will not waste your time here now by
repeating it now before we do begin it's
worth mentioning that we reached out to
faze clan so we could talk to their
legal counsel as well and get their side
of the story on this one they did
decline to comment which is of course
their right and if they change that
we'll update you in the future
devious lawyers of course Brian Friedman
he is a high profile california-based
entertainment lawyer a partner in
Freedman and tatelman so let's start by
very quickly boiling down this 23 page
lawsuit to the very basics according to
Freedman basically it's saying two
things number one that faze clan is
violating California law by acting as a
talent agency in the state of California
while not being licensed as such number
two that the agreement is in violation
of section
16600 of the California business and
Professions Code what exactly does that
mean we'll get to it now why this
actually matters beyond being illegal is
that if faze clan is doing this it means
they don't have to abide by the laws and
regulations that govern talent agencies
in the state of California so Freedman
says that if they were a licensed talent
agency that people would have never had
to sign this original Gamer agreement in
the first place because no regulatory
body would ever approve it had bathed
plant applied for a talent agency
license and obtained the talent agency's
license they would have then had to have
their contract approved by the
California Labor Commissioner any
contract such as the
they have could never be approved by the
Labor Commissioner and therefore T foo
would have never been handed a contract
that would have looked like the one that
he got because any licensed talent
agency would not be allowed to use a
contract such as that
now the second thing that the lawsuit
contends is that T Fu's original Gamer
agreement violates section
16600 of the California business and
Professions Code which states quote
every contract by which anyone is
restrained from engaging in a lawful
profession trade or business of any kind
is to that extent void end quote
the other action is a lawsuit in a Los
Angeles Superior Court and that lawsuit
is based on in part a violation of
what's called 16600 of the business and
Professions Code and what the code
stands for is you cannot illegally
restrain an employee or an independent
contractor in California from working
for someone else
basically Freedman says that if you're
designated as an independent contractor
and not a full-time employee that you're
not bound to be employed only by a
single group or business so no matter
what you hear from all the drama videos
out there those are the two main thrusts
of this lawsuit now one of the more
interesting conflicts between the
lawsuit and tifa's Gamer agreement is
that a lawsuit was filed in California
and alleges that the gamer agreement
breaks California law however the gamer
agreement has a clause in it that states
that any legal action around that gamer
agreement has to take place in the state
of New York
so which one supersedes the other well
according to Freedman perhaps
unsurprisingly it ain't gonna be New
York faith plan their principal place of
business is in California they operate
out of California they're incorporated
in Delaware there's absolutely no
reasonable relationship to the state of
New York
now of course makes sense that tifa's
own lawyer would take that position but
I also talked to a few other lawyers who
specialized in eSports and at least one
of them Josh Marcus of Toronto's mkm
group law agency seems to agree the
allegations with regard to
a California statute would be brought in
California you know I don't think
there's any question that that's the
right jurisdiction for that court and
certainly there's no reason why T foo
can bring a claim that the contract is
oppressive or violates any California
laws that that would still be brought in
California now one of the main points in
all of phase clans communications since
this lawsuit came out is the reiteration
that they've gone back to t foo time and
time and again with better and better
contracts that have you know better and
better revenue splits and that they're
trying to make things right and trying
to get him on as best a contract as they
can and Freedman does confirm this
however he says that the contracts that
phase presented TP with behind the
scenes when this whole thing started
weren't even legal those contracts
provide for a legal procurement also
without a talent agency's license and
even worse those contracts actually try
to get Turner to waive the California
talent agencies Act and the illegal
procurement provisions which is by the
way legally unenforceable because
they're to protect individuals and
artists and no one could possibly find
something like that that would be so
illegal
now speaking of new contracts one of the
most interesting things Friedman told me
which i think is completely new
information in this case is that it
wasn't just faze clan presenting t foo
with contracts T Fu's team actually
presented faze clan with a proposed
contract and they rejected it
faithlyn was presented with the contract
Turner would accept it was you know as
close to a legal contract as you can get
but apparently that wasn't good enough
for them and they decided to mark up
about half of it get rid of about half
of it put in their own provisions which
again made it illegal
once again this is really interesting
because it challenges the narrative of
this whole controversy up until now
until Friedman told me that it had
seemed at least to me that the entire
point of what T foo was doing was just
to get out of a contract that it didn't
matter about any 8020 splits and he's
$60,000 nothing in the details matter
that T foo just wanted to get out from
under
clan and faith claim would do anything
to retain him because he was so valuable
to the brand now if this is the case if
it is true that T Fu's team offered a
legal contract to faze clan and they
essentially rejected it that challenges
that now Freedman began representing T
Fuu after his team had presented that
contract to faze clan so he wasn't able
to tell me any details about why faze
clan would reject it and frankly I'm
still confused isn't the game here from
faze clan side of things just to keep T
Fuu on faze clan they don't care about
making a dime directly off of T Fuu his
value to the brand is there just being
on the brand I would really love to get
faze clan side of the story especially
in regards to this particular issue and
again I'm gonna keep trying and if they
do update me with any information I will
be sure to pass it on to you guys
another figure that got tossed around a
ton in the first few weeks of this
controversy was the $60,000 figure
specifically faze clan saying and their
communications that they only took sixty
thousand dollars from t food when it
came to this dollar amount Freedman was
not impressed saying that it's
completely disingenuous and does not
represent T Fu's value to faze clans
brand first of all what why are we
sitting around believing that they only
took sixty thousand dollars you know how
you could rely on their sixty thousand
dollar figure as to what they made off
him it's disingenuous I mean you realize
how much money faze clan is making by
having Turner as part of its team how
much advertising they're selling how
many sponsorships that they obtain
because Turner was part of their team
it's almost laughable to think that they
are saying that they took sixty thousand
dollars from him and that's it when
they've made millions of dollars through
sponsorships with Nissan and other
companies by virtue of the fact of
having popular gamers the most popular
of which was Turner so to say that
they've only made 60,000 dollars off
Turner into complete fiction and doesn't
take in the reality of
how much they've made on their videos
how much they've made on their YouTube
channels how much they've made through
sponsorships brand deals and otherwise
by utilizing Turner's name and likeness
and by having Turner at part of the team
now since we're past that forget about
the $60,000 and forget about any 80/20
splits because neither of those things
according to Freedman were the most
egregious the most shocking parts of T
Fu's original game or agreement is what
they think is the most shocking
provision in this entire agreement and
that's the agreement that says that at
the end of the term that he has to sit
out and can't play any video games
online publicly for six months and and
why would that provision if you ask
yourself be in a contract or someone
like him think about this if he doesn't
go online doesn't stream doesn't play
for six months what will that do to his
following and his subscriber base and
his career it will absolutely
irreparably harm his career so how you
could have an illegal provision that is
essentially a non-compete that does not
allow him to compete or even on his own
to do his own craft and stream or
publicly play video games online for six
months is shocking and I'm really really
surprised that that's not a part of the
contract that people are looking at and
saying wow that's unbelievable that
would destroy someone's career another
piece of clarification I got from
Freedman was regarding the original
parts in a lawsuit surrounding underage
drinking underage gambling and tifu
allegedly being pressured into doing
dangerous stunts very quickly after the
lawsuit was filed tifu came out with his
own video saying specifically that he
wanted those allegations removed from it
Freedman told me that he agreed with
that and indicated that those
allegations would be taken out and that
that is not the point of the lawsuit at
all technically it's like an
attorney-client thing but I respect my
client and to the extent that there's a
mistake couldn't they
or there's something in there that he
didn't want in there all on that and
that's not an issue at all and I think
he's right in the sense that you know
it's really not what you know
notwithstanding the fact that banks
comes out admit to the underage drinking
it's not what it's about they're just
not what the case is about it's really
would've never been about so what
happens next
it's been almost a full month since the
lawsuit was originally filed and T Fu's
legal team started this whole process
back in September now this perhaps isn't
the most shocking thing in the world but
according to Friedman one way or the
other
t foo is getting out of his contract
it's gonna happen one way or the other
base class contracts is going to be
deemed to be illegal going to be deemed
to be void and they know it and they
know they've been violating the law it
doesn't take very much to stand up and
be honest about it to say you know what
we had some poor ownership before and
we've tried to change the way we do
business and we're going to do business
differently and you know we're gonna do
it with Turner and I think that's the
ideal situation barring that it's going
to be the courtroom it's going to be in
front of the Labor Commissioner and the
Labor Commissioner is going to look at
this contract labor commissioners going
to look at all the illegal procurement
that's happened the labor commissioners
gonna void this contract and say no no
no can't treat people like that you
can't operate as an illegal talent
agency and try to get away being unlike
and you know I'll just put the question
back to you right would you go to a
doctor that didn't have a medical
license for eSports lawyer Josh Marcus's
part he feels that it is more than
likely that this case will be settled
out of court which means unfortunately
we probably won't get a lot of the dirty
details going forward
odds are already that this case will
settle given the publicity I'd say it's
even more likely to settle given that
you know there's been a lot of numbers
thrown around here I would love for this
matter to go to trial I'm sure you know
certainly all the lawyers would and
the media would because then we could
actually see what comes out in the
evidence we'll see how much players are
making and where that money is coming
from and that will all be a matter of
public record even so he says that this
case has already made a significant
impact on the eSports industry
you know I wouldn't hold your breath for
it for exciting news coming out a
lawsuit anytime soon but certainly it
has the industry up in in a buzz that
you know teams I can tell you are
certainly more cognizant of issues like
this coming up in the future and we've
seen a few teams say hey we would look
at our contract and tell us just how
unreasonable or whether whether it's in
line with the industry is really better
the better way of putting it and you
have at the same time I think players
are more cognizant to the fact that they
need help reviewing these contracts and
you know it might be a dream to go and
play video games for a living but the
excitement has to kind of take a
backseat to reality now Friedman says
that whatever happens he hopes that this
won't just resolve things for T foo but
actually changed the way faze clan
operates he ended our interview by
issuing a challenge to face class I
challenged faith to do the right thing I
know that a judge and the Labor
Commissioner will find in our favor and
I know that we will win but it shouldn't
even come to that because faith as an
organization should be a thousand people
and it should be about protecting people
and it should be about doing things
legally and properly and that would help
everyone thanks for watching if you want
more content like this hit the sub
button and ring that notification bell
for unique bite-sized videos you won't
find anywhere else hit up art Instagram
Twitter and Facebook pages
[Music]